sans eau pas d'agriculture et peu ou pas
d'aliments produits mais avec le
réchauffement climatique les
précipitations sont de moins en moins
importantes ce constat implique une
meilleure connaissance et préservation
des ressources en eau c'est le but de la
plateforme aux adns observatoire de la
zone non saturée
le plus grand réservoir d'eau français
est sous les pieds des habitants du
Loiret et de l'Eure-et-Loir c'est la
nappe de Beauce pour analyser ce
réservoir sans fonctionnement et son
état de santé un puits bardé de capteurs
a été construit dans le nord du Loiret
sur une ferme céréalière conventionnelle
cette plateforme est un dispositif parmi
tous ceux du programme Junon visant à
créer un jumeau numérique de
l'environnement régional une banque de
données sur l'air les sols et l'eau
le fait d'établir des jumeaux numériques
pour nous ça a été vraiment l'occasion
d'avoir un lieu une zone dans laquelle
on puisse chacun contribuer alors par
exemple les numériciens apportent tout
ce qu'on peut faire en termes
d'intelligence artificielle les gens qui
sont plus experts dans l'environnement
l'eau l'air le sol selon leur spécialité
apporte leur expertise pour comprendre
comment les ressources naturelles
évoluent au cours du temps c'est-à-dire
d'arriver à avoir des des chiffres des
choses qui soient modélisées qui donnent
une vision globale de l'impact
donc là c'est des expériences en colonne
de laboratoire c'est pour étudier les
processus de transfert des polluants
objectiver l'impact de l'agriculture sur
l'eau de la nappe de beau c'est un
travail de laboratoire les données
collectées dans le puits de Carthage
sont étudiés ici elles ont déjà permis
de comprendre que les pesticides mettent
en moyenne 30 ans pour descendre du sol
jusqu'à la nappe l'enjeu est maintenant
de tester des molécules dont l'action
phytosanitaire sera en adéquation avec
la sauvegarde de l'eau
l'objectif principal est de tester des
molécules
avec un terminologie simple
biodégradable dans la durée de vie est
relativement courte de façon à ce qu'on
garantit la fonction attendue d'un
pesticide et on évitant la nuisance là
pour l'instant elle est fait collabo
après on fait par modèle dans le milieu
naturel parce qu'on voit bien comment
elle réagir et après on aura peut-être
des parcelles dédiées pour faire des
tests pour être sûr que toute la chaîne
de vérification est efficace dans deux
ans un premier point sera fait par les
scientifiques pour juger la pertinence
des données collectées en bosse il
faudra aussi en 2025-2026 un vrai
consensus de tous les partenaires pour
valider la faisabilité des jumeaux
numériques et leur intérêt face aux
enjeux climatiques
demain c'est une expérimentation menée
en viticulture que vous découvrirez et
notamment ce robot 100% électrique